[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to next car game a game that
promises realistic soft body physics and
if you don't know what that means
I mean just just kind of watch holy crap
its deformable bodies with actually
interacting physical parts that break
and smash in realistic ways it's totally
awesome so holy crap I'm gonna play
around for a little bit in this little
playground they got here and you guys
can watch the mayhem and enjoy come here
come here on blood no I barely got any
blood do you're gonna okay well alright
then Wow where did I go oh where am I
going
okay just had to get that little piece
of my body out of my body ass
oh God I wonder what's gonna happen to
us now okay I seem to have some minor
body tablets while I'm going to head
towards that spider now if I could yeah
steer in a correct direction I wouldn't
have this much trouble okay please like
can I please cut could you place it's a
blaze Bob write what they do please
cooperate with me pal God ow
Wow
anam okay goodbye cruel world Howie I
can't go anywhere oh I made it
oh if you call that making it than I
made I can't turn over when I'm on my
back oh this is course I'm not supposed
to know I'm not supposed to go down
there I'm just saying heap oh my god I'm
still trying to go it's okay little
buddy
you can give up now hello goodbye oh
this is a bad idea
Oh God boy what big feet you have the
better to do that with oh yeah oh yeah
holy crap this is awesome oh my god I'm
falling apart but look at me go why am i
falling apart I have no idea really I
would love to get it just a roller derby
going on in this big ball big giant
rolling ball with big giant rolling
balls what could be better
Oh this was probably a mistake putting
all these balls in here so how many
balls can actually fit in here I can't
stop adding balls I'm at a loss for
words oh yeah
I think my cars in there somewhere but
that is awesome
ow I was going for the other thing thank
you very much mr. spider damn it let's
get some points baby wait oh cinematic
camera right in there are we ha ha ha
my car why I can still drive question
mark not well though I don't know
exactly where I'm going now but hey I'm
doing it I think what am i doing where
am I going wait a minute I missed
no visitor mistake laughs you're a dick
suck on that didn't mean to do that okay
just gonna just just gonna carry on my
way now thank you thank you what do we
have here a giant Plinko machine oh hell
yeah
okay here we go big money big money yep
ow oh come on that was pathetic you're a
worthless lump Hana barrows is that a
cannon is that a legitimate cannon I am
so going in the cannon please fire me ow
fire me oh where am I going oh it's a
nightmare
boy these are some nicely stacked things
would be a shame if someone ruined them
hello how's this oh oh yeah oh yeah
these are just so nicely stacked how can
I not hit him oh my god this is so cool
okay those are cement blocks I can't
exactly hit this but I'm gonna try I'm
gonna get you
yeah oh hi mr. cannon oh my front end
could you please fire me correctly now
thank you oh wow okay this is good
I wanna be in you oh you missed me come
on he said all you got
bring it on you brought it
wowie oh my goodness
boom boxes alright looky-loo let's see
what you got bring it on oh my goodness
oh I love it I love it
mini-ramp we boxes I missed him I'm
misty and our friends
I guess is where cars go to die why did
I not see that before oh god why oh why
is everyone driving into it why okay I
gotta admit this is pretty awesome
bring it on yeah God just look at the
physics of this thing it's amazing my
buddies have fun at school hey friend
what are you doing what happened to that
guy cuz it's kinda sticking up out of
the ground oh you look so helpless Oh
Mitch I almost forgot that I have a
freaking rocket launcher now bring it on
[ __ ] Oh bring it on you spidery ow
all I'm shooting pieces of myself where
am I going oh I broke it I broke it I
broke it I broke everything why did I
break everything yeah Bobo Bobo God look
at that
oh my goodness okay then oh lordy lo
matches gobble me Fox's Pilar's matches
yes destruction
raining down upon you there's a
cannonball I'm throwing apparently it is
what is happening why is it happening
I'm gonna get you spider bastard come
here wow you're eating me okay that was
probably a mistake on my part so it's
just you and me now ignore those guys
over there cuz it's you and me yeah oh
I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna get you
[ __ ] yeah yeah go get him buddies okay
you're dying over there I'm just gonna
go on my way now thank you
okay my dad yet think I'm dead haha
get on [ __ ] hey you guys wanna play a
game it's called exploding complaining
your turn is gonna be quite
hey on a piece of me brah on a piece of
me brah gonna okay have fun
you look great you look real good okay
good good
hi again are you having fun yet you want
you want to get off the ride why why
would you want to do that just having
the time of your life get in there you
bastard you get in there what happened
did you get in there did you get in
there you look good I'm gonna get out
here I'm busting free oh I was so close
come on
outs outs outs outs cables okay gotta
get it gonna get it good long wind-up
long wind-up hit my target stay on
target
stay on target stay on target
Wow
into the five yes yeah on to a ball yeah
all right guys that was next car game
amazingly fun the physics engine in this
is the best I've ever seen in anything
like it is absolutely amazing and I have
a very powerful computer so I wasn't
lagging much but still the fact this is
possible in real time and technology
today that was my car you've douche you
are going to get owned you son of a
[ __ ] with like that your son of a [ __ ]
get out of it that was my gold card spot
anyway this game is tremendously fun I
think it's like fifteen or twenty
dollars on Steam and that may seem like
a lot because it's technically a tech
demo but still I want to see this
physics engine in everything in the
future I want everything to have this
it's so awesome
so anyway links in the description thank
you all so much for watching leave a
like if you enjoyed the video and as
always I will see you my car in the next
video
[Music]